In this video, we'll show you how to activate your BurpSuite Enterprise Edition license.
The first time you log in, you'll be prompted to activate your license key before you can
begin using the product. First of all, make sure that your Enterprise server can connect
to portswigger.net on port 443. If your server does not have direct access to the internet,
you may need to configure an HTTP proxy server, so have these details handy. Your BurpSuite license
covers a single deployment which can have multiple scanning machines and run multiple scans. If you
want to deploy the BurpSuite Enterprise server in multiple environments, for example you want to
have a separate Enterprise server and database for your test, development or staging environment,
then a separate license would be required. You can download your license key from the account
page of your Portswigger account. You then need to log into your Enterprise server and you'll be
prompted to upload your license.
If your license is activated successfully, the system displays a confirmation message
showing the details of the license key. If a connection to portswigger.net could not be established,
you will be prompted to configure an HTTP proxy before continuing.
the system will be required.
The system will be required to deploy the system.